happy monday reject nation and happy end
of the month to you if you clicked on
this video sync your fangs into that
like button
morbius jokes all right guys we got our
final trailer from orbeez today had a
lot of footage released this movie i
think is finally coming out i hope we
get footage of matt smith this time
that's that's like the main thing i'm
hoping for
or or spider-man stuff andrew garfield
that's all i want anyway keep looking
for a batman review that's gonna come
out in just like a couple of hours from
now along with like 55 other people
that's batman
let's do this people
[Music]
michael morbius discover who you're
meant to be
the bad guy
oh cool whoa
definitely calling on those life vibes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but a cure
it's curse
very cool
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice to hunt
and consume blood
or die
we all have monsters within us
yes we do control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
interesting we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
[Laughter]
a new marvel legend arrives the biggest
legend yet all right well that was a
good trailer that was good what i liked
about it is that it didn't feel like it
was trying to be like spider-man reliant
seemed like it was all focused on just
michael morbius his own personal
dichotomy and like what do i do now with
this new curse is it a gift is it a
curse am i a hero and my villain i like
how i lean heavily into that i like that
we actually got some of matt smith he's
the 11th doctor and doctor who that's
where a lot of people know him from and
i think he's just a fantastic actor
brilliant doctor i haven't read any like
leaks on this movie you know anything
that i talk about has all been stuff
that's only been theorized and i know
sony's kind of popular for plot leaks
but i actually don't know any leaks for
this specific film in the comics lexia's
crown he's a friend of michael morbius
and he has like a similar condition and
he goes down the villainous path where
he becomes a vampire of his own but he
becomes the villain hunger one thing
that this trailer seemed to show is that
some of those flashbacks in the
orphanage it seems like the way at least
they spliced it together with him saying
like like what we've suffered with our
whole life how do i figure out what the
exact line is but it seems like they
maybe grew up together in the orphanage
and they do have a history of being
friends and then now he comes back into
his life later down the road and he's
probably going to be the main villain
here so it seems like he's kind of torn
between two worlds where you have you
know the character you might know the
actor's name the guy's playing nicos
who's like a mentor to morbius oh yeah
jared harris jared harris that's his
name jared harrison yes more of a good
representation of like no you can do
something good with this you're michael
morbius you're a scientist you're out
there to help people and then you
probably have you know matt smith's
character who's trying to tempt him to
go down more of the villainous path more
traditional vampire type of portrayal
who who delights in uh this this
supernatural ability and you got michael
keaton being like i'm forming a sinister
six
or something all through the power of
dialogue editing yeah i don't know if
none of half the dialogue in this
trailer feels like it comes from the
actual scenes they're putting it over
but yeah i i'm really excited that's the
most exciting thing to me about this
trailer is the prospect of seeing laxus
crown and michael morbius interacting
together seeing their history together i
mean jared leto is a meme at this point
but he can turn in a great performance
some of the time and matt smith is
always terrific no matter what character
he's in and that was the easily the
thing that got me the most excited about
this trailer but this also felt like the
most well-rounded trailer too in that
yeah it's not relying too heavily on
spider-man even adrian tombs feels a
little bit more like he's plugged into
this direct movie and might directly
affect morbius's story in an isolated
sense rather than only serving to bring
him into some kind of spider-man related
scenario which is probably what will
happen you know i just like that this
movie this trailer here seemed like it
was mostly focused on the movie at hand
and you get a really nice look at like
his entire power set from what i gather
here the director of this did life which
you know at least had a pretty decent
rep for replicating that sort of intense
aliens type of vibe and it looks like
the horror stuff and this is gonna have
a pretty decent punch to it as well and
that's pretty exciting to me to see
somebody actually deliver when they say
they want to make a horror-centric
marvel movie of some kind well i'm
fascinated with if you could pull off
the pov type of you know uh super power
element because sometimes i got really
worked actually like amazing spider-man
does that really well or it could be
just kind of goofy and cheesy but
but at the very top of this trailer when
they are doing the cargo ship scene
pulled straight from the comics that
scene i liked how they were showing a
lot of that through like morbius's pov
and they're keeping it masked it feels a
little bit like uh i don't know a
sequence out of alien or something like
that seeing a little bit more of like
the tone of that that feels more like
vampire movie
esque i guess the thing is you know like
while morbius does become anti-hero in
in the comics and himself you know this
the trailers if i'm remembering the last
one they also still lean heavily into
you know are you a hero or are you a
villain and and this the one request
that i have for this movie is
that you'd lean a little bit more
towards the bill really make it a
conflict like i'm i'm thinking like when
nico's hey i'm wondering if they will
kill him off here i really don't know
i'm wondering if he will die at the
hands of morbius that's kind of the
impression that i'm sort of getting
because you don't really see much of
jared harris other than the same scenes
they keep pulling from so i keep
imagining that maybe morbius he gives
into his temptation and kills him right
there on that bench yeah
thanks for the advice buddy so i just
really want them to lean uh heavily into
that but i am curious to see what this
movie does manage to establish with the
spider-man universe and where this
ultimately does take place in that
specific timeline other than that guys
morbius i can't wait to actually see
this movie been delayed 29 times
here we are now christmas 2025. all
right guys well thank you so much for
being here and keep a lookout for a
batman who we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
you